another grim day for the met in trouble
this time officers at one of its most
famous police stations and the offensive
text they sent to colleagues
one male officer to another i'm going to
smack her to one female officer i would
happily rape you to another if i was
single i would happily chloroform you
women who complained were told play the
game or stay quiet
other messages were racist and ridiculed
the disabled the officers said it was
all just banter
it was the sort of culture that drove
adam pugh out of the force
it's so historical and it's so deeply
ingrained that i don't really believe
that there is any way to reform that
culture i don't believe that there's a
way to change it certainly not from
within
and ultimately that was why i left so
that i could pursue that change and
speak about that change from the outside
rather than from within we need to move
away from the bad apple narrative and
acknowledge that it's actually the tree
that is rotten
and the tree that is burying bad fruit
and that good
good apples or good well-intentioned
police officers can still be a part of
the problem
the police watchdogs investigator said
the behaviour we uncovered was
disgraceful and fell well below the
standards expected of the officers
involved our investigation showed the
officer's use of banter became a cover
for bullying and harassment colleagues
were afraid to speak out about these
behaviors for fear of being ostracized
demeaned or told to get another job
two officers were fired and others
disciplined
the iopc made 15 recommendations and
ordered the met to tackle underlying
cultural issues there's clearly a small
but a
significant minority of people in the
met who have let us down on many
occasions and the the behaviors on this
occasion are completely deplorable
and the the comments that we've seen
that have been made and come to fruition
as a result of this investigation are
completely offensive and there's no
place for them here in the met
home secretary pretty patel said there
had long been a problem with the met
police culture standards she said must
be raised
martin brunt sky news